انخفاض شديد في درجات الحراره في الشمال
السوري يقابله ارتفاع في اسعار الخبز
ليفاقم ظروف العيش الصعبه في منطقه
القامشلي سوريا من اعمار مختلفه ينتظرنا
لساعات للحصول على بعض الخبز باسعار
مناسبه
وما نقدر نشتري ربطات خبز
رغم الظروف القاسيه الا ان ملامح
الانسانيه ما زالت موجوده تطوع هذا الرجل
السبعيني لتسجيل اسماء الباحثين عن لقمه
الخبز حتى لا يضطر الى المبيت في الشارع
واحد وراء واحد ويروحون العالم كلها تفضل
من الشالات وعلى بيته وتروح يرتاح
على الصبح يجي واحد اسمه محمود ياخذهن
ويصيح الواحد
الافران الشعبيه في القامشلي لا تتجاوز 15
فرنا
ومخصصاتها من دقيق القمح لا تتجاوز الطن
الواحد في حين ان حاجيات السكان تتجاوز
ثلاثه اطنان لكل فرن في ظل الاقبال الشديد
من اصحاب الدخل المحدود
اوضاع صعبه يعيشها الفقراء في الشمال
السوري في ظل المناشدات بتوفير كميات اكبر
من الدقيق للمخابز انس نماسي العربيه